les marseillais est ce que vous allez
rester dans les marseillais au point ben
en fait c'est une fois la question en
fait les répondu en fait bien sûr ouais
ça c'est dans l'air glacé sur les vite
répondu la même question à vitry plan de
jeu ben en fait non non clairement on a
décidé d'arrêter sa découverte saison
vous étiez dans ce set en sept ans carla
six ans et c'est une décision compliquée
quand même on s'est connu là bas on a
town a tout fait on a une petite fille
mène anciens parce qu'on s'est connu la
balle je touche pas à mon poste
du coup on fait cela on a décidé de
prendre cette décision n'est pas facile
quand même parce que quand ça fait sept
ans que tu fais la même chose
c'est dur de prendre cette décision
était bien avec cette production
franchement c'était c'était vraiment
bien vite pour vous arrêter parce que je
pense que pour notre bien personnelle
c'est la chose à faire
après comme j ai vraiment n'était ils
ont été vraiment cool avec nous c'est là
que ça sur la production que ce soit pas
gars quand on adore génial rivage ici
car on les adore aussi allemagne a pas
d'embrouillé entre vous ça n'a pas été
une décision facile après à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui on a vraiment tout donné
dans cette famille des marseillais
maintenant on a aussi envie de penser à
nous il aurait voulu nous revoir là pour
les prochaines aventures mais ça c'est
une décision qu'on a prise ensemble
qu'on a mûrement réfléchi et on s'est
dit c'est peut-être le bon moment de
partir pour faire autre chose quelque
chose qui nous correspond à nous quelque
chose peut-être de mieux pour nous
comment il avait annoncé la production
aux anciens
ben hammam ancien camarade pour tout
dire je l'aï dit cas pas cas d'accord
mais parce que c est lui carrément que
je suis vraiment un jour avec
après les autres on a préféré en parler
directement à la production pour leur
dire il était déçu de pour découvrir et
essayer de vous retenir ou pas oui après
c'est compréhensible ça fait sept ans
qu'on fait ça et bien alors à nous ça
fait dix ans ouais mais de tous à y
aurait même presque tous s'accrochent et
en question oui il ya un pote à moi qui
me demande qui de vous deux vous
demander si le mec a mis la c1 tarbes a
ou pas bien sûr non c'est égal mais
quatre ils répondent d'ailleurs toi tu
veux pas tardé thaçi j'adore le but
vous êtes triste de quitter l'émission
ou pas ou c'est nous c'est une
libération non matière un peu triste de
quitter en fait non plus souvent la plus
un peu le groupe qu'on avait et comme
j'ai dit en fait c'est vraiment ce qui
est la production et au avec qui on
s'entendait vraiment bien après je pense
que pour nous c'était le moment de
partir voilà on va pas se mentir c'est
ce qui les attend qu'on fait ça ça on
apprécie les super année c'était
magnifique mais je pense que voilà ce ce
moment opportun pour calmer les marchés
cet ep dur je te goures ne l'est pas
parce que c'était bien passé c'était
plaisant à faire